La distancia que una persona puede ver en un día claro se estima por la fórmula
"v" es igual a 1125 raíz cuadrada de "a"
todo eso sobre 1000, donde "v" es visibilidad,
esta "v" de aquí es visibilidad en millas y "a" es altitud, eso está claro.
Ahora nos dicen si Jerónimo puede ver 150 millas,
eso es qué tan lejos alcanza a ver,
esa es la visibilidad.
Así es que esto es "v"
¿A qué altura sobre el suelo se encuentra?
Así es que nos están preguntando,
¿cuál es la altitud?
¿A qué altura sobre el suelo se encuentra?
Esta es entonces "a", la cual desconocemos.
Sabemos que su visibilidad es de
150 millas y queremos encontrar "a".
Aquí tenemos esta fórmula de visibilidad
en términos de la altitud,
sabemos cuál es la visibilidad
es de 150 millas,
así es que "v" es 150 millas,
así es que podemos establecer que "v"
ó 150 millas es igual a 1225
por la raíz cuadrada de "a",
y "a" es la altura a la que se encuentra,
así es que por raíz cuadrada de "a",
y todo eso, todo eso sobre 1000.
Ahora
multiplicando ambos lados de la ecuación,
lo que queremos es dejar solo este radical
para después despejar "a"
multiplicando ambos lados, entonces,
por 1000 entre 1225...
por 1000
entre 1225 y también del lado izquierdo...
déjame hacerme un poquito hacia la izquierda...
por 1000 entre 1225.
El objeto de esto es dejar sola la raíz cuadrada de "a", así es que este 1000 se cancela con este 1000
y este 1225 con este 1225,
¿y qué obtenemos?
A mí me gusta más dejar del lado izquierdo
la variable que estoy despejando,
así es que también voy a invertir
los lados de esta ecuación.
Tenemos entonces del lado izquierdo
la raíz cuadrada de "a"
y del lado derecho tenemos este término de aquí,
este término de aquí que sería 1000
por 150,
y todo eso
dividido entre 1225 entre 1225
y parece que esto lo podemos simplificar.
Me parece que estos 2 números son divisibles entre 25,
veamos 150...
150 es 25 por 6
déjame escribirlo aquí,
esto es
25 por 6 y 1225
2500 es 25 por 100
1250 es 25 por 50, este número es 25 menos,
así es que este número es 25 por 49,
si es que no me está fallando la aritmética,
chequemos eso por acá
49 por 25
esto es igual a 5 por 9 = 45 llevamos 4,
5 por 4 = 20 y 4 = 24 esto ya no me sirve,
luego 2 por 9... primero pongo el 0...
2 por 9 = 18 llevamos 1
2 por 4 = 8 y 1 es 9,
hacemos la suma 5, 8 y 4 = 12,
2 y 9 = 11 y 1= 12
1225 correcto.
Así es que aquí podemos simplificar
25 y 25 primero déjame deshacer de este 1225,
este 25 se va con este 25,
y ahora me parece que este 49
ya no lo podemos simplificar más,
es 7 por 7 así es que esto
ya está en su mínima expresión.
Así es que esto es igual a 6000 sobre 49
lo cual es igual a la raíz cuadrada de "a".
Ahora, si queremos despejar "a"
podemos elevar al cuadrado
ambos lados de la ecuación.
Déjame reescribir la ecuación acá abajo,
tenemos que la raíz cuadrada de "a" es igual a 6000
sobre 49,
elevamos a ambos lados al cuadrado,
elevamos al cuadrado la raíz cuadrada de "a" y elevamos al cuadrado 6000 entre 49
¿y qué tenemos?
Esto nos da igual, del lado izquierdo es "a"
la altura sobre el suelo a la que se encuentra Jerónimo,
y esto es igual a 6000 al cuadrado...
6000 al cuadrado sobre 49 al cuadrado,
o puedes dividir 6000 entre 49 y elevarlo al cuadrado.
Calculemos entonces este valor
para conocer la magnitud de la altura.
Déjame sacar la calculadora para esto.
Venga a la calculadora...
déjame borrar este comando...
y ahora si, he aquí la calculadora.
Tenemos entonces
al cuadrado
entre
y esto nos da
1400 o más bien,
voy a redondear,
esto es 14994 pies,
esto
es igual a
14993 pies
y estoy suponiendo que esta ecuación está considerando que la altitud está en pies,
no lo mencionan aquí pero, tiene que estar en pies para que esto haga sentido.
Si puedes ver hasta 150 millas hace sentido de que te encuentras alrededor de 15000 pies sobre el piso.